quels sont vos coups de coeur qu'elle
filme peut-on regarder pendant cette
période de confinement c stand by me de
rob reiner un film de 1986 j'ai trois
atouts pour lequel j'ai choisi ce film
le premier c'est que c'est une
adaptation réussie d'un roman de stephen
king
alors ici il n'y a aucun élément
horrifique comme dans shining ou dans sa
ni aucun élément surnaturel comme dans
la ligne verte
c'est juste un récit initiatique qui en
fait composé d'un souvenir marquant de
quatre adolescents qui vont partir dans
la forêt et qui vont vivre une aventure
qui va les aider en fait à passer à
l'âge adulte
donc ça fait un moment donné un peu peur
mais c'est surtout formidable et ça
n'est jamais angoissant totalement donc
c'est un film extrêmement juste cette
histoire pleine d'événements c'est une
promenade riche et à la fois touchante
et très profonde
du point de vue de gérer psychologique
d'autre part les acteurs sont tous
excellents et j'en citerai un seul qui
ait river phoenix la river phoenix en
fait c'est le petit frère de joaquin
phoenix vous savez l'interprète de joker
et river phoenix dans ce film il n'a que
16 ans et il est promis à une très
grande carrière parce qu'il est
excellent néanmoins malheureusement sept
ans plus tard il sera victime d'une
overdose et ce sera un deuil pour toute
la famille phoenix tous les personnages
sont bien caractérisée il ya le sage
philosophe il ya le pacifiste
intelligent il y a le balourd qui est un
peu le souffre douleur
et puis l'enfant battu qui est agité
plein plein de colère donc tous ces
jeunes vont constamment fonctionner à
l'écran enfin une dernière chose très
importante c'est qu'il ya une excellente
bo dans ce film et
dont la chanson stand by me la fameuse
chanson tube de ben king a donné en fait
son titre au film
noah justement c'est une chanson cam
hardcore absolument unique dans toute
l'histoire de la musique
elle a été un tube dans les années 50 et
grande cinq ans plus tard elle redevient
un tube numéro 1 8 par an pendant des
semaines mais sans aucune modification
de la chanson c'est d'ailleurs c'est
l'interprète initial avec les musiques
initial et le rythme initial
ça c'est absolument unique même les
beatles ou michael jackson n'ont jamais
eu ce type de record à 35 ans
d'intervalle la chanson est deux fois
numéro un dans un pays majeur comme les
états unis